By its very nature, television is generally
scripted.
Whether it's an actor performing in an episodic
drama or comedy, an anchorperson presenting
the latest world news, or a quiz host welcoming
an audience to a show, almost everyone who
appears on TV says and does exactly what they're
supposed to.But that isn't always the case
- and we're not just talking about specifically
improvised shows like Whose Line Is It Anyway?
Even shows that are scripted have featured
moments in which actors and performers have
gone off script - and sometimes with great
results.In this video, we're going to run
through some of the best off-the-cuff moments
to have been aired on television - both in
live action and animated shows.
Here are ten hilarious improvised TV moments
you have to see.
Friends
Friends is one of the most iconic and beloved
television shows of all time - and one of
the most brilliant lines from the hit sitcom
came courtesy of some great Jennifer Anniston
improvisation.
It was in the episode The One After Vegas,
when Ross and Rachel woke up after a drunken
evening in Sin City with no recollection of
the fact that they had gotten married to each
other the night before.
When they were informed about it by the other
Friends, Rachel responded with the line "This
isn't a marriage, this is just the world's
worst hangover!" which was superbly made up
on the spot by Anniston.
House
Hugh Laurie is an outrageously talented actor,
so it should come as no surprise that one
of the funniest scenes in House - a medical
drama in which he starred as the titular character
Gregory House - was totally ad libbed by the
Brit.
In the opening season two episode Acceptance,
Laurie's character was mad at James Wilson
for having sided with Stacy Warner in a quarrel.
In response to this, House said "Look, I know
you're friends with her, but there's a code!
Bros before hos, man!"
It was so unlike anything you'd expect him
to say that it was hilarious - and it was
clear to see that Robert Sean Leonard who
plays WIlson was cracking up about it!
Community
In the Introduction to Teaching episode of
the great sitcom Community, one of the show's
main characters - Abed Nadir, played by Danny
Pudi - begins taking a class discussing popular
Hollywood actor Nicolas Cage.
When he gets up in front of the class to deliver
a presentation about Cage, Pudi improvises
a scene in which he suddenly starts acting
like him - going totally crazy and speaking
in an overly dramatic fashion, just like Cage
often does in his movie roles.
Everyone in the class looks totally stunned
- and it's hardly surprising!
They didn't expect to see Abed as Cage acting
like a "sexy cat" that day!
Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
The Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
season two finale was a two-part episode entitled
S.O.S.In the second part, S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent Leo Fitz invented a high-tech device
that prevented the Inhuman character Gordon
from using his teleportation powers.
When Gordon asked how Fitz had managed to
do this, actor Iain de Caestecker improvised
with the Breaking Bad-inspired response "Science,
biatch!"
His co-star, Clark Gregg who plays Phil Coulson
in the show, tweeted that the line was the
“Best ad lib in the history of television"
- and it's hard to argue with that.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
Joss Whedon is known for his brilliant writing,
so when he's penning a script, very little
improvisation is required or requested.
However, in Buffy the Vampire Slayer, an entire
exchange between two of the show's most beloved
characters was entirely ad libbed by the actors
who played them.
Alyson Hannigan's Willow Rosenberg and Seth
Green's Oz had a cute discussion about Animal
Crackers in the episode What’s My Line Part
2 and the whole thing was made up on the spot
- including the fun line Oz says about all
monkeys being French.
Bob's Burgers
Bob's Burgers is an animated sitcom that is
known for its vulgar humor.
However, one of the best moments in the show
came in the episode entitled An Indecent Thanksgiving
Proposal, which featured an improvised (and
completely non-vulgar) song by voice actor
John Roberts, the voice of Linda Belcher.
The song in question was "The Thanksgiving
Song" and was sung by Linda to annoy her husband
Bob while he worked.
Such was the song's popularity that it was
even covered by indie band The National and
was cited by the show's writers as one of
their favourite numbers in the entire series.
Scrubs
This entry is a little different to the others
on this list, because it refers to almost
every scene involving a certain character
in the brilliant medical comedy-drama Scrubs.
Neil Flynn portrayed the mysterious and hilarious
Janitor in 166 episodes of the show and the
show's main star, Zach Braff, has said that
the actor made up most of his lines.
In fact, Braff has described Flynn as a "true
genius improviser" and has stated that the
show's scripts would often simply say things
like "Neil makes something up and then exits".
Having done that for eight years, you have
to give the guy a lot of credit for that - especially
bearing in mind excellent lines like "I spent
the day inside that wall, thinking I was a
merman..."
The Simpsons
In The Simpsons episode You Only Move Twice,
the brilliant Albert Brooks guest-starred
as the eccentric owner of the Globex Corporation
- and Homer's new employer - Hank Scorpio.
Scorpio seemed to be the perfect boss (before
being revealed to be an evil genius, that
is) and encouraged Homer to implement his
own ideas.
One of those ideas was that his team were
given hammocks, because working so hard was
making them tired.
When Homer went to Scorpio with the idea,
he loved it and Brooks improvised a scene
in which he said hammocks could be purchased
at the nearby "Hammock District".
Writer Josh Weinstein has since said that
Dan Castellaneta's reactions as Homer were
"exactly like someone talking to Albert Brooks".
Parks and Recreation
Given its incredibly talented comedy cast,
you'd be forgiven for thinking that a lot
of Parks and Recreation was ad libbed - but
you would also be wrong.
That being said, one of the funniest lines
in the show's entire run was made up on the
spot by none other than current Hollywood
superstar Chris Pratt.
In the episode Flu Season, Pratt's character,
Andy Dwyer, typed his co-worker Leslie's sickness
symptons into his computer to find out what
was wrong with her.
In a completely improvised moment, Pratt's
character then stated that the computer had
deduced that Leslie was suffering from "network
connectivity issues", which is undeniably
brilliant.
The Office
Ever since the original British version was
airing, The Office had a reputation for having
some of the most awkward scenes in television
history - but none were more awkward than
a hilarious improvised moment courtesy of
Steve Carell in the U.S. adaptation of the
show.
It came in the episode Gay Witch Hunt, when
Carell's character Michael Scott offended
his employee Oscar Martinez by calling him
"faggy" without realising Oscar was actually
homosexual.
As a result, Michael attempted to reconcile
with him in front of his workforce by giving
him a hug.
The improvised moment came when Carell's character
added a kiss to the scene, shocking Oscar
Nunez - the actor who played Oscar Martinez.
The look you see on Nunez's face when the
kiss happens was a genuine reaction, and it's
pretty damn funny.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 hilarious
improvised TV moments you have to see.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other examples are you aware of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.